sur ce clip de propagande les
séparatistes pro russes montrent lusine
azoff stahl a frappé par des
bombardements intenses selon les
autorités ukrainiennes l'artillerie
lourde les chars et l'aviation sont à
l'oeuvre dans l'offensive une situation
extrêmement difficile comme témoigne ce
commandant présents sur place
ça fait deux jours que lemmy à pénétrer
sur le territoire de l'isi il y à des
batailles lourde et sans ondes je suis
fier de mes soldats qui font des efforts
surhumains pour contenir la pression de
winne
des centaines de militaires mais aussi
des civils dont des enfants sans
nourriture ni médicaments serait
toujours retranché dans les galeries
souterraines d'azov stahl ces images de
la télévision russe montre les troupes
de moscou attaquer
même si le kremlin dément avoir
déclenché un assaut
les militants restant dans la zone
industrielle d'azov talent sont bloqués
en toute sécurité dans le périmètre les
appels répétés aux nationalistes pour
qu'ils libèrent les civils et déposent
les armes avec la garantie de sauver
leur vie et d'être traités dignement
conformément au droit international ont
été ignorés
de son côté volodymyr zelensky appelle
l'onu à l'aide mardi avec le concours de
l'organisation plus d'une centaine de
civils évacués étaient arrivés à
zaporizhya
une opération qui pourrait se répéter
les forces armées russes annoncent
qu'elles vont ouvrir un couloir
humanitaire pendant trois jours à partir
de ce jeudi entre 8 et 18 heures